how's it going bros my name is you bros
know that i love music
based games and one of you bros
suggested in the comment this game
called Oh soo it's free it looks it's
supposed to be like not apparently not a
lot of people know about it it's a free
game and it looks really cool so we're
gonna check it out okay let's go play
solo oh my god oh my god what is
happening
Oh sue okay I don't oh my god I have to
collect on the salad nice salad but
whatever this is the greatest game of
all time
I can't anime as [ __ ] like a nice [ __ ]
whoa
what the actual [ __ ] is going on
no I was trying this is hard oh my god
this is giving me anxiety I can't oh my
god yeah
yeah it's going so fast and I can't even
think come on I'm playing on normal oh
god oh oh my [ __ ] god are you are you
[ __ ] kidding me
okay what am I even supposed to click
that fast
yeah
spin it spin it this game is awesome
it's raining on his head spin it
I'm spinning
yeah what the [ __ ] is this
I'm gonna not do this guy too much to
scan the place mother's Judas
all right play with the keyboard oh my
god oh my god are you kidding me how in
the heaven's name am I supposed to do
that yes I'm [ __ ] good at games look
at this [ __ ] what's up
any meal spinach man I'm gonna be so
cool when people see me playing this
game holy [ __ ] I'm 26 years old
oh god what is happening I regret
everything in my lap oh my god
laptop over that
Oh sue okay um what the [ __ ] just
happened
that gate was awesome I can't believe
it's free and it's such a like great
game with that it seems like it has a
great community behind it as well so
check it out if you want to I had a pump
playing I hope you enjoyed as well if
you did feel free to leave a like and
right now it's a great time to do it
Ambrose I think it's so much for
watching I'll see you in the next video
as always stay awesome bro let's pretend
that we're a school and we need to drive
our kids to school and be really [ __ ]
short on time my god we made that jump
like a [ __ ] boss